ich glaube dass die mittel die hitler
nahm in mutiger machten durch sie hätte
vielleicht entscheidungen getroffen die
er sonst nicht getroffen hätte
mit sicherheit hat er im frühen stadium
des krieges das gefühl eine extra
stimulanz zu brauchen dringend in seine
arbeitstage wurden immer schwieriger
moore war ein quacksalber er war zwar
ein ausgebildeter mediziner
doch er stand auf alternative
heilmethoden er machte sich unersetzlich
zum schluss kam hitler keinen einzigen
tag mehr ohne seinen drogencocktail
verschrieb ihm alles wonach ihm der sinn
stand
er wurde mehr und mehr zu seinem
vertrauen in den oberen rängen wurde der
konsum von drogen akzeptiert viele
hochrangige nazis waren schwerst
drogenabhängige pervitin war die
wunderpille denn damit brauchten die
männer keine pausen mehr
sie konnten drei tage lang durch die
welt der agenten brechen und immer noch
weiterfahren
sie brauchten keinen schlaf das war ein
immenser vorteil
[Musik]
[Applaus]